hey guys what's up I'm Alanna or char
Ilana Zod and welcome to my channel
today I'm going to be answering the most
common question that I get asked which
is how did I get a job at IGN it all
started in primary school to cut the
education part very short I just want to
wrap it all up by saying that I always
excelled in English I always wrote a lot
and I always wrote even in my spare time
this is something that I think is very
important to stress because I think
there are a lot of people who want to
work in games media or want to write for
IGN because they like games rather than
because they like writing I never want
to discourage anyone from trying to
learn a new skill or to improve in
something but if you don't like writing
and you only want to write about games
it might not be for you
you might want to consider all of the
other things that are to do in games
that you have maybe historically been
good at or are passionate about so after
graduating high school with relatively
good grades and a definite strong suit
in English I went on to study a Bachelor
of mass communication majoring in of
course journalism and entertainment to
backtrack a tiny bit I actually started
writing about games before I started
studying the way that I happened upon
that was basically I was looking for a
job just after graduating high school
and I found a listing on a website for a
volunteer games news write-up for a very
small website I started writing for that
website twice a week and I think I
worked there for six months or so I
don't remember but during the time that
I started writing for them I also
started writing for other websites as a
volunteer there were websites and
magazines that I found that I knew
because they were local and basically
what I started to do was compile
everything that I had written put it on
a separate website which I actually used
a tumblr blog and then I would reach out
to these websites on Facebook or Twitter
and say hey here's my work I'm really
passionate about this I would love to
write for you so I wrote for a bunch of
different websites completely for free
for I think around a year and I think
around the six months mark was where I
actually started to study at the same
time as well from there I started using
Twitter a lot more often I started
interacting with editors and community
managers on Twitter and trying to build
relationships whilst also sharing links
to every single thing that I wrote so
those people who I was getting to know
by a Twitter would also see all of my
work so I don't remember my timeline
perfectly but I did get to
point where I was using a casual job
that I was working on the weekends to
pay for my flights to go to events to
cover games in person and to meet other
people who worked in the industry I
found out about them by social media all
because I had asked community manages or
PR reps for their email addresses
I was absolutely zero dollars in my bank
account because everything I was doing
was being invested in this career and it
was at one of those events that I
actually got my first writing job I was
arguing with someone about why I like
taalib and he came up to me afterwards
and I think he said something like hey
I've seen some of your writing I thought
you were very articulate in that article
I want you to review games for us I will
pay you to do that I think this is
probably around the same point in time
where I started my youtube channel I
started my youtube channel as a way to
lend a video edit and to get more
comfortable on camera so it was
basically at the same time where I was
building up a video presence that he
eventually paid me to review games for
his website and things just kept kind of
going that way and that I used that to
pitch to other magazines or other
websites around that time was just after
I'd started making videos so I was
trying to get on video for more
companies so I was doing the same thing
that I did with writing full video is
basically contacting companies and
saying hey I want to make these videos
for you I think there are three separate
companies that have been relatively
heard of at this point that I was the
first one to make a news video for them
because I pitched them with it was also
around the same time that I was getting
a lot more comfortable in camera that I
started to pitch to radio stations and I
actually ended up getting a position on
a local radio station in Brisbane so I
was live on radio every Wednesday which
was awesome that's four triples edge
shot out to Zed games I love you guys
one of the things that I did in that
hustle was apply to a competition that
Xbox australiawow having to send someone
to e3 to be an Xbox insider I did not
win that competition I don't think I was
even a finalist in that competition but
it did mean that they knew who I was and
I think six months after that had
stopped being a thing I got a call from
someone who worked at Xbox Australia who
I guess had been keeping in the loop
with my writing in my videos and they
asked me to be the Xbox insider which
basically meant going
to events interviewing people and being
first impressions of games for xbox
australia's social channels so
everything was kind of coming together
and I was doing a lot of different
things and it was all in the interest of
we trying to get my name out there and
do things for free until I basically
felt like I had reached a point where I
had enough experience was confident
enough and was getting enough good
feedback that I kind of hit a point
where I was like I should be paid for
this so I'm pretty sure took two and a
half years until I got my first
full-time position at that point I
recognized that there was a ceiling in
Australia for the games industry
I used my degree to get me transferred
to the US as an international student
entirely with the goal of ending up at a
place like IGN and I applied for a job
in May of last year at IGN I had I think
three interviews it was like hours that
was one thing where I was interviewed by
like nearly 20 different people I think
in one day it was pretty crazy
but because I was still a student uh and
I was on a student visa the visa process
was really hard so I was technically
told that I had the job in May 2015
but I didn't actually start watching by
IGN until November 2015 because it took
that long for me to get a visa
it was rough and I'm pretty sure that
that covers everything I think so uh
it's hard to recount everything you've
done for the last five years but I
really hope that I haven't forgotten
anything Here I am going to disable
comments on this video but if you have
any more questions I will do my very
best to answer them as always there will
be links below to all my social channels
I do have to give a shout out to the two
people who supported my channel after
the last video which is Austin Foss and
Kyle Allen thank you guys so much this
is just absolutely amazing
YouTube is totally a thing that I do in
my spare time off the insane walk hours
so um I seriously just appreciate that
you guys appreciate that I guess
thank you guys so much I love you and
that is it for me today everyone I will
see you guys next time okay